I wanted to tell you about the maths of
my new tattoo
so I got recently tattoo this is a
hyperbolic helicoid and so I was going
to explain the math of Gila coins and a
little bit of hyperbolic space so I
actually went into the tattoo parlor
with the line work and the shading and I
had an artist who was kind enough to
actually transfer that onto my body I I
wanted to make sure it was
mathematically correct so one of the
things about it is that helicoid ZAR
something that showed up in my PhD an
awful lot and i'm an aficionado of
hyperbolic space anything negatively
curved so I combined them and made a
tattoo this is my first tattoo but may
get more mouth tattoos in the future so
helicoid are a type of surface that's
called a ruled surface a type of surface
that is made entirely out of straight
lines so I've got straight lines that
are displayed here and I can change the
number of lines on the surface and I've
got other parameters that I will be
changing throughout so one thing you'll
see is there's this opacity here so this
is showing the full surface so I can
turn turn that on so you can see a bit
of surface and see how it's being filled
up with lines
this here is going to be the simplest
rolled surface you can possibly have is
the plane it's just created with a whole
bunch of straight lines so I can just
continuously fill it with straight lines
this is the hyperbolic paraboloid it's
also called a high power surface I'm
gonna basically sort of twist up the
ends of these and so this is my
parameter here I call height so as I
stretch it I end up with this surface
here this is something you see in
architecture a lot this is in a lot of
rooms actually you see a lot of ruled
surfaces in architecture because it's
very easy to get straight objects and
then it's just about the way you
assemble them that gives you a curvature
they're all still straight everything
you can do about them in straight so
then it's what I'm going to show you is
hyperboloid of revolution so what I'm
going to do this has four lines now I'm
going to continue to add lines in this
makes it a cylinder and I'm going to
turn on my surface so there's a bit of
surface back here so what I'm gonna do
is each of these lines I'm gonna twist
it right about here and that is going to
start moving it around and it will
become this is a hyperboloid of one
sheet so you might recognize this shape
as the cooler for nuclear power plant so
that is the the canonical shape for that
that is this shape here turns out but
the two surfaces I showed you are
specialist surfaces because they're not
ruled just once but they're doubly
rolled so I can take two sets of
straight lines to construct the same
surface it's interesting because they're
made in the straight lines it's almost
like there's no real curve that you're
just creating the illusion of a curve
yeah it is a bit like that but if I were
to make them infinitesimally small and
start filling them in one by one by one
I would sweep out every single points on
the curve on the surface and that's what
makes it a surface and not just us out
of curves so these ones are doubly
rolled so I can turn on the other
rolling so here I have a set of sort of
crisscross lines and those will rotate
together to form those curvature so now
to my favorite surface is is the
helicoid so helicoid is something that
keep a margin starting with a plane and
then you start filling it in with lines
like this but this one I'm going to
instead of like we did with the high
power surface twist it this one twists
at a constant rate that one twisted not
at a constant rate and here we're gonna
end up with a surface that looks quite a
bit like a wind chime so helicoid is a
surface that's constructed of straight
lines that rotate about a central line
Otacon
right so let's get to the tattoo so the
tattoo is a hyperbolic helicoid and it's
done in a particular model called the
poincaré disk model and the first thing
we really need to understand is what do
straight lines look like in this face so
I have all of space is in a disk and
this is the boundary is infinity and if
I have a point at the very center a
straight line is a straight line that
passes through the center so this is a
straight line if I had say another point
over here a straight line that would
pass through that point is going to be
something like this so this is an arc of
a circle and it intersects the boundary
in right angles so this is what straight
lines are in this particular model we
know what straight lines are and I'm
going to make a helicoid out of them so
this is what it looks like this is the
the line I'm gonna rotate about and this
is the straight line I'm gonna rotate so
this one this one is the 3d once I need
to have this is the plane but for me to
twist it I need to have a third
dimension to twist into so now it's the
same rules of the lines are defined by
the same rules except we're using a
sphere instead of a circle yes it should
be turning more than now I've got lines
and they're gonna touch the boundary of
a sphere and they have to intersect that
in ninety degree angles I'm gonna start
filling in lines up and down to make my
plane you can imagine this is a whole
plane so what does that plane look like
is that plane quite flat I can't quite
tell it is flat this plane right now is
just a cross-section right through the
middle of this fear so it's completely
flat both in our version of space and in
hyperbolic space so this is just the
half of this fare right here so now that
I've got a plane that's pretty full and
I'm gonna start twisting around that
line so once it twists quite a lot
you'll start seeing something that looks
reminiscent of my tattoo so once it gets
to here
I'm gonna add some more lines to make it
look a little fuller this is the surface
that you my tattoo is based on it is
called the hyperbolic helicoid so it is
a helicoid it is a rolled surface based
on twists of a constant rate and this
one happens to be in hyperbolic space
and then the other thing about my tattoo
is so this is straight but I can
actually change what the center line
does so I kept calling it a curve before
I started with a straight line but I
don't need to keep it a straight line I
can let it twist around too so that and
then the plane goes along for the ride
those when the plane goes along for the
ride yeah it's taking the curve and
pulling the North Pole around down
towards the equator zero is up top and
PI over 2 is at the equator so that's
what I've done here so my tattoo I
believe is that PI over 2 so it's a
quarter of the way around the circle I
want to see your tattoo again now
looking at the South Pole and the North
so the North Pole is not right above the
South Pole it's kind of bent is it
yeah so I've again pulled this the
centerline is one of these straight
lines so it is also a curve that meets
the the sphere Android angles so what
I've done is I've pulled it down so that
the North Pole of this and the South
Pole of this are I guess one is at the
South Pole and the other it's at the
equator ok but sort of towards mates
yeah it's not a I rotated it so that you
got to see both poles
so helicoid they're not just a ruled
surface they're also a minimal surface
and those are surfaces like so films and
things like that and that's what I've
spent a lot of years of my life studying
in particular there's a theorem that
says minimal surfaces locally are either
bits of helicoid or pairs of pants and
pairs of pants is actually a technical
term and so I've spent a lot of time
looking at how to decompose surfaces
into healed codes
there's a conference we always go to
which is called bridges we went there
and they do math art so I had set up a
gallery and they said well I mean you
can go do over whatever you want just
need your shoulder here and we'll show
up with there has to be art pieces now a
tattoo is getting very interactive with
your mathematics and you might not want
to go that far but if you do want to
interact with mathematics why not check
out brilliant the sponsor of today's
video by the way brilliant loving the
new look of the website very nice now
here's the daily challenges these are
always really good fun where are the
holes I'm looking at that if you mount
and fold a square piece of paper in half
twice then fun which one are you gonna
get a B C or D I'm going a incorrect
anyway that doesn't matter getting
things wrong is what it's all about
sometimes I'm brilliant they're not
there to judge that is there to have fun
enrich your life do check out their
courses they've got loads of courses
they're adding new ones all the time
fantastic love the new look 3d geometry
- this is going to keep you entertained
for days weeks months check it out
people
brilliant org slash numberphile and
that's going to give you 20% off a
premium membership and that's access to
everything on the site it's a treasure
trove people brilliant org slash
numberphile they go really big on the
interaction now which of the following
shapes could not be a cross section of
the cylinder I've got to be de Shirley
ah again oh yeah I see I could have
liked
put up there
[Music]